he said his dad is like friends with a
marine biologist or something yeah and
they went out and took water samples in
San Diego and he was like it's like the
worst it's ever been I don't want you
guys that was like I want you to stand
up paddleboarding I don't you just surf
anymore because you like shouldn't even
be in the water there's like so much
[ __ ] bacteria and [ __ ] really yeah
well it's crazy dang I know so you're
just you're doubling down second though
yeah I'm going twice a day now I'm
trying to get like I'm trying form like
mutations and [ __ ] toxic waste
eventually that's how we're gonna evolve
good yeah that's what we're gonna
actually grow another dick I was
thinking like gills or something you
just come from the water one day you're
like oh [ __ ] oh yeah I snap look at your
ribs yo you snapped on the scale snap
bro know your gills are dulled your
gills are sick you did presenting the
water you come back up your eyes are all
bubbled out your hands are webbed not
[ __ ] me like this dude dude I was with
the gills that was tight yes not chill
why is my mouth movie bro bro we're
seriously living like fish bro are we
fish right now we [ __ ] fish I feel
like this is an actual servers nightmare
like turning into a fish telling the
story somewhere he's like bro then I
woke up yeah and I swore I was a fish
gills dude
[Music]
is that Dustin phone these are custom
pump this are gusting phone these are
just all in my bag on my wrists all
emotion